President Biden says the risk of nuclear
Armageddon is at its highest since a
Cuban Missile Crisis of the 1960s the
U.S president warned that a Russian
leader of Vladimir Putin is not joking
when he talks about using nuclear
weapons following losses on the
battlefield in Ukraine in the latest
incident a Russian missile strike
destroyed an apartment building in the
southern city of zaparisia and this came
as Russian forces lost more ground to
Ukraine's counter-offensive in the south
and east
gutted by Russian Rockets
here in zapparesia rescue workers
searched the rubble for missing
residents local officials say several
people were killed while more had been
hospitalized
after the initial Dawn attack
firefighters headed to the scene
but a second Salvo sent locals running
for cover
as well as rescue workers
president zielinski condemned the
strikes
after the first rocket strike today when
people came to pick apart the rubble
Russia conducted a second rocket strike
absolute violeness absolute evil and
there have been thousands of instances
of this already and there could be
thousands more unfortunately
locals were left reeling
why are they doing this to us
what are they trying to prove killing
old people
why for what
the attacks come as Ukraine continues to
force Russian troops back in the south
and east
with these Ukrainian troops in the
donbaths telling French reporters that
they were using shells captured from the
Russians
with winter fast approaching Kiev seems
determined to press its current
Advantage as long as it can
straight to Ukraine then Nick Conley
joins us from Key welcome Nick we'll
come to President Biden's comments in a
moment a fur so this attack on zaparisa
seems to be part of a Russian patent
defeats on the battlefield followed by
attacks on civilian infrastructure
yeah
well that's definitely the way it looks
and that's what the Ukrainian government
has been talking about for a few weeks
now we've seen attacks on heating plants
on electricity infrastructure also on
water infrastructure so there's a sense
here especially leading to this winter
situation for civilians could get a lot
worse even for people living quite far
away from the direct fighting that they
could be stuck in high-rise Apartments
without the ability to heat their homes
or even the electricity to go about
their work their businesses and there is
this sense that Russia wants Ukrainian
civilians to put pressure on their
government to make compromises that that
is basically the last hope you know
short of the kind of nuclear
um brinkmanship that we've been seeing
in recent days and that that is now
going to increase it's interesting we
tried to report on the situation on what
Ukraine is doing to repair that
infrastructure but they won't let us
anywhere near it they are very very
worried that anything any information
could provide clues to the Russians
about what else they could destroy and
what else they could do to weaken these
companies countries infrastructure and
this nuclear brickmanship is something
that the U.S president has said that we
should take very seriously because this
is not a threat this is that this is
this is something that we should uh Mr
Putin's threat is a series is something
that we should take seriously the
biggest threat since the human Missile
Crisis uh what are people there in Kiev
say
well that's the interesting thing so
basically up until the last couple of
days people just haven't been taking it
seriously they've been seeing it as kind
of symptom of Russian weakness of
desperation an attempt to kind of
escalate given those kind of Russian
failures on the battlefield uh and
basically kind of saber rattle I think
what really has made people think here
have been those comments from the US not
only from Joe Biden but also in previous
kind of days and weeks from retired top
us generals who've been kind of talking
about what NATO the US would do in case
of a Russian use of nuclear weapons
talking about you know seeking the
Russian Fleet attacking all Russian
troops on Ukrainian territory I think
that really has made people think that
you know the US is taking this seriously
and we've seen how precise those U.S
intelligence predictions were running
into the war when people here didn't
want to believe that Russia was going to
launch full-scale Invasion and those
American predictions turned out to be
right so there's lots of kind of nervous
talk about buying iodine tablets working
out what to do if a nuclear attack were
to happen and even lots of kind of dark
humor about Raves and the kind of things
people would do on their last few days
after a nuclear attack so there's a kind
of attempt to try and kind of lighten
the tone but people now increasingly
thinking about this seriously and
thinking about what to do and all of
this because Ukraine's counter-offensive
has been so especially effective in the
last few weeks what is the latest on
that
so we've heard figure coming out of the
Ukrainian military establishment they
are talking about 500 square kilometers
retaken in the hersson region in the
South just in the past week the details
are pretty sparse they're keeping a very
tight grip on meter access and so those
details are kind of filtering through
quite slowly but definitely there's a
lot of panic on Russian social media
among the kind of military blogs people
who support this war who are really
worried that those Russian forces in
Carson are going to be stuck on the
Western Bank of the Nipper River without
any supplies coming in the bridges have
been destroyed and the ukrainians are
really you know hammering home with
their artillery so there's a sense that
they're going to be more Ukrainian
victories next couple of days while they
try and take advantage of their kind of
uh you know momentum before the winter
sets in and you know the front lines
kind of get more stuck and kind of Less
Mobile in a couple of weeks all right
Nick thank you for that Nick Connelly in
Kiev
on the counter-offensive has come at a
terrible cost thousands of soldiers have
died and there are constant casualties
on both sides DW correspondent Matthias
bullier was given access to the front
lines near mikalayev by the Ukrainian
Army and sent this report
these positions are well fortified
Ukrainian soldiers have withstood
several months of shelling in these
trenches the Lions haven't moved to most
of that time but recently things started
shifting up ahead they've started to
attack Russian positions more
aggressively
in some directions we have been able to
move forward even right now an attack is
going on we try to put them under
constant pressure so it'll go our way
let me show you where our guys live
let's always just stay here for several
months the Army doesn't have enough
Personnel to rotate them in and out more
often this group is getting ready for
the cold season
actually
in Winter we will have to heat all of
this space we'll be in his own by then
let's hope so for God's sake
two days ago a shell hit just above
their beds
thankfully the roof is so well built
further behind the lines ambulances wait
for injured soldiers to evacuate into
hospitals
we're told that three ukrainians were
hurt while storming a Russian position
Frontline paramedics hand them over to
an ambulance that shuttles between the
war zone and the hospital
[Applause]
Ukrainian authorities have admitted to
roughly 10 000 dead soldiers that's well
below estimates of Russian losses but
neither side are releasing precise or
credible numbers
foreign
this time none of the injuries seem to
be severe
[Music]
the counter-attack is costing Ukrainian
blood the paramedics say they've become
busier recently
the number of injured is higher during
the attack because our guys move forward
to the positions of the Russian villains
and then it's easy for the Russians to
hit them because they know their
positions well and can shove them
the paramedics returned to their waiting
position they don't know when the next
trip to the hospital will be but they
know it will come